okay so i'm just going to show it one
time okay
otherwise you can okay okay so this kick
is here
all right and it goes it kicks
his face out i'm not left happy
my power has to be in there then i'm
gonna catch it
so i just show it one but i can tell if
you have the right geometry or not then
you could you could boom this place
okay so it can't be jammed
deflection deviation
angle the tap all all at one time oh
catch when you catch
same thing out of range
it's got to be boom or my body can come
in
and even though i made a phasing stance
it's still grounded
it's still grounded boom
i'm not just turning my hips and hoping
to knock them out with momentum
my body is hitting here okay
so sweet spot boom and we're gonna test
you don't push push push push push
with no extra leaning changing weight or
anything
okay